i think the lakers feel they can be you
had a chance to see this this team in
person they won in friday against
orlando and the clip that was being
shared everywhere was you and russ
chopping it up now whoever recorded it
was talking so much we couldn't hear it
and i love your house what were you guys
talking about are those flowers what
yeah those are flowers yes from the
bahamas
i was just telling right like you know
people think we have we have an argument
beef that's not the case
i love russ i care about russ he's done
a lot for the game and when you're that
caliber player and you're not playing
well people take shots
i don't like to see people coming my guy
like rust like that so i'm watching i'm
analyzing i was like
i finally see his problem
like he wants to do so good he's going a
thousand miles an hour so my man slow
down you know like the one play he he
starts to fast break back there
and then he's fast but not as fast as
the old rust and then the young guy
caught up with him and turned out it's
like bro
take your time slow it down and then
explode don't give the guy time to react
like if you start back at 94 feet full
speed guy's gonna turn you get the wreck
so i was just telling him bro just slow
down you know just take your time so you
said slow down how did he respond he was
like man man man you know i'm just
trying to get a riddle i said no slow
down slow your game down pace yourself
you don't have to go a million miles an
hour and did he listen after that i mean
you know he had a couple players where
you know he scored and you know he
played well you know they they played
with karma carmelo already heated up
that night at 19. in the second half but
that's his only problem well he just
needs she just needs to slow down
i mean like you know because like when i
first got there he shot the bank shot
and it hit the top of his name but
he was even rushing that i'm like well
man take your time and shoot the ball
you know how to shoot you know how to
play you've been in big moments before
none of this should startle you just
slow down and play
i don't know if wade would have taken
that advice but hey that played us up a
slowly yeah as you get older yeah you
get slower